welcome everyone my name is priyana
tarajan and I'm the current director of
the Frankie program in science and
humanities
I'm delighted to invite you all to this
evening's wonderful event as part of our
distinguished author series first I
would like to start by recognizing our
benefactors Mr and Mrs Richard and
Barbara Frankie and their support at the
Frankie program Yale's Flagship
interdisciplinary program as well as
multiple other initiatives at Yale that
they support
so I want to remind you that as Ty
mentioned we have a wonderful reception
upstairs after the talk so please do
stay for that it's in the student lounge
room 131.
and since we are recording this talk I
am required to read this out to you that
Yale University is photographing and
videotaping this event there's a
possibility that you may be included in
these visuals by being present during
these activities you consent to the use
of your appearance likeness and Voice by
Yale University for standard non-profit
educational news related Promotional and
or editorial purposes
So today we're in for a real treat from
one of our own distinguished faculty
Professor Beverly Gage who is a
professor of history and American
studies her research interests lie in
20th century U.S history government and
political development and ideological
movements she teaches a wide variety of
extremely popular courses that focus on
American politics government and social
movements today she will be talking to
us about her new book G-Man J Edgar
Hoover and the making of the American
Century
this book has done incredibly well it's
completely unsurprising if you have
opened up and read started even reading
the first couple of pages the writing is
brilliant the analysis is incisive I
highly recommend getting a copy if you
don't already have it
so G-Man received the um
in Beverly received the 2022 Bancroft
prize in American history and was named
a best book of 2022 by Washington Post
in their list of 10 best books the
Atlantic in their 10 best books
Publishers Weekly in their 10 best books
the list is very long but I'll read some
of them just to show you how
spectacularly successful
Beverly has managed to re-engage us with
this very complicated man all over again
so the New Yorker in their 24 essential
reads the New York Times in their 100
notable books and in the Smithsonian in
their 10 best history books she's also
the author of The Day Wall Street
exploded a story of America in its first
age of Terror which examined the history
of terrorism in the late 19th and 20th
centuries focusing on the 1920 Wall
Street bombing in addition to her
teaching and research Professor Gage
writes for numerous journals and
magazines including the New Yorker New
York Times and Washington Post in 2009
Professor Gage received the Sarai
ribikov award for teaching excellence in
Yale College in 2015 she was she has a
very long list of honors I'm going to
give you like a short pressy because I
don't want to take up you know air time
so in 2015 she was elected to serve as
the first chair of Yale's faculty of
Arts and Sciences Senate from 2017 to
2021 she served as the Director of
Yale's Brady Johnson program in Grand
strategy and in 2021 President Joe Biden
nominated her to serve on the National
Humanities Council which is The Advisory
board for the National Endowment for the
Humanities at Yale with Professor
Elizabeth Hinton she leads the workshop
in modern U.S history a monthly speaker
series for faculty and graduate students
to discuss the latest scholarship in
20th century U.S history
and she's also deeply one of her own
she's a graduate of Yale University and
from the America and has a degree in
American studies and finished her PhD at
Columbia in history so without further
Ado I would like to turn the floor over
to Professor Gage thank you so much
Beverly for coming today
well thanks for that generous
introduction thanks to the Frankies for
their support of this program and to all
of you for turning out on a nice spring
day in a windowless room uh at the end
of the semester
uh so I think the plan for today is that
I'm going to talk for uh you know about
40 45 minutes and really just try to
give you an overview of this book that I
published in November
um that is uh as Prius suggests is sort
of making uh the rounds in the world and
then leave time for some real q a at the
end I've found that in talking about Jay
Edgar Hoover who as you will hear lived
a very long time and did a very many
things that my overview is useful but
that many people come to this subject
from many different directions and many
different interests and have many
different points of intersection so I
want to make sure that we get to the
things that interest you about Hoover as
well as the things that interest me
when most Americans think about Hoover
in the 21st century one of two images
comes to mind the first and I think most
prominent is of Hoover as sort of the
great villain of the 20th century
um someone who abused Americans civil
liberties was one of the most
manipulative powerful and most hated
figures in all of Washington
the second and slightly more puriant set
of images that often come to mind
they're really more a product of the
1990s or a set of questions about
Hoover's sexuality his private life most
prominently uh the story that emerged in
the 1990s that Hoover liked to wear
women's clothing so I'm going to get to
both aspects of that part of his image
as we go through the talk and as I did
in the book itself but to start I wanted
to present a different image this is
Hoover's funeral in May of 1972
he was the first civil servant ever to
lie in state at the U.S Capitol and
there are a couple of things that I
think are important about starting with
this image
first is that by the time he died he had
been in office as director of the FBI
for 48 years so almost half a century
this is a cartoon that I reprint in the
book and I highly recommend picking up a
copy of the book even if you don't buy
it because I managed to persuade my
publisher to publish 130 photos which
was a little bit of a struggle but I'm
going to show some of them here today
but there are a lot of good ones in
there this is one of them and this is a
cartoon that was done in 1968 when
Richard Nixon was elected president that
shows all of the different presidents
that Hoover had served under from Calvin
Coolidge to Richard Nixon Hoover became
head of this little organization known
as the Bureau of Investigation in 1924.
under Calvin Coolidge as you can see
there
he stayed on through the presidency of
Herbert Hoover so that was into the dawn
of the Great Depression the crises of
the late 1920s and early 1930s he then
remained for all three plus terms of
Franklin Roosevelt's presidency this is
Roosevelt seated Hoover is uh the kind
of youngish man standing right behind
him that's Roosevelt signing some crime
legislation so he stayed on through the
New Deal the lead up to the second world
war and all of the second World War
he was then there through both terms of
Harry Truman's presidency so that's the
dawn of the Cold War the years of
McCarthyism
he then stayed on through both terms of
Dwight Eisenhower's presidency so the
tail end of McCarthyism uh the
conservative as well as liberal politics
of the 1950s
he they stayed on through John Kennedy's
presidency he was there under Lyndon
Johnson through many of
the dramatic changes in crises of the
1960s and then he remained under Richard
Nixon and died toward the end of Nixon's
first term still with the same job the
head of the FBI
so when I have told people over the last
decade plus that it took me to write
this book that I'm writing a biography
of Jay Edgar Hoover often their first
question is why in the world would you
want to do that and I think often what
people mean by that question is why
would you want to spend so much time
with this villain uh with this terrible
man who is reputed to have and in fact
did so many terrible things
and one piece of that answer is simply
this sweep of time that Hoover was there
for so long doing so many different
things that he's not only interesting in
his own right as an individual but is
interesting to me as a vehicle into some
larger story about 20th century American
politics and I think tells us some
things that aren't as evident when we
look in other places
so I just want to mention a few of those
things and a few of those big themes
that I try to emphasize in this book and
then I'm going to run pretty efficiently
I think through uh through the book as a
whole and then open this up for Q a
so one thing that I think that we can
see when we look at Hoover as a vehicle
for thinking about the 20th century
rather than some other ways of thinking
about our politics is a story that's as
much about government as it is about
politics my book is called G-Man which
stands for government man and it's
called that because that was the
nickname for FBI agents beginning in the
1930s so it's a it's a catchy title in
that sense but it also conveys one of
these big themes that I try to get
across which is that this is a story
that is about politics but it's about
governance and in particular it's about
the growth of the state the federal
government over the course of the 20th
century when Hoover became director of
the FBI in 1924 it was this little
organization known as the Bureau of
Investigation there were a few 200
agents they didn't actually have a whole
lot to do by the time he died in 1972 he
had about 16
000 employees the FBI's jurisdiction had
expanded dramatically and the size of
the federal government as a whole had
expanded really dramatically I think
when we look at our political history
very often uh
certainly in public discourse to some
degree in the historical profession as
well there tends to be a lot of emphasis
on political parties political figures
elections ideology and Hoover's part of
that story but he sort of turns our lens
toward the administrative State toward
this vast world of executive power and
administrative power that really
operates outside of electoral control in
many ways and that in some ways becomes
I think the bigger story of the 20th
century or at least one of the most
significant political stories there
and within that Hoover is a really
interesting character
um he is someone who was really
interesting to me as an ideological
figure because I think he represents two
strains of our political story that we
don't often see combined very well
together one is that he was from his
earliest years really a true believer in
this vision of federal power in what we
might describe as a kind of progressive
or liberal vision of state power that
involved professionalism that involved
non-partisan service that involved
career service to the government that
involved the use of Science and
expertise to serve the public good
and on the other hand he was throughout
this whole time a really deep
ideological conservative on questions of
race on questions of religion on
questions of Law and Order and above all
on anti-communism which is really the
big theme of Hoover's life and I think
you know what fascinated me about his
story
of what we don't see very often I think
in our own politics today is the
combining of these two Traditions into a
career that lasted for a very very long
time in the book I characterize him as
something called a conservative State
Builder but someone who essentially used
the tools of the liberal State including
the New Deal which is really the moment
that the FBI gets his power but used
those tools really to serve a variety of
conservative causes in the end and made
those two pieces work together so that's
sort of the political puzzle of the book
and then of course one of the other
things that Drew me to Hoover was simply
the opportunity to reinterpret a figure
that actually hadn't been Revisited in a
very long time there were about 30 years
have passed since the last round of
Hoover biographies and even when I
started working on this book which was I
will admit in 2009 so about 13 years ago
even then it was clear not only that
Hoover was in many ways ripe for
reinterpretation but that there were a
whole host of new files that had come
out about Hoover and it seemed like an
opportunity to delve into those in
particular files that had come out since
the end of the Cold War that I think
really helped us to rethink some of the
ways that we narrate the struggles over
communism and anti-communism in the 20th
century but lots of other files that
have come out as well some of them
through the Freedom of Information Act
some of them files that I myself
acquired through the Freedom of
Information Act others that were
released in a routine way by the FBI so
I am you know in my core really a kind
of archive nerd a history nerd I love
sitting there with these giant piles of
files trying to figure out things that
we didn't know before and I will say uh
the uh the amount of information
available about a figure like Hoover is
both part of the appeal of writing this
book which I will warn those of you who
haven't seen it is about 800 pages long
that of course is one of the big
challenges of doing it how do you not
read absolutely everything but read
enough to find out things that are
really new and interesting and of course
in Hoover's case uh that basic problem
of uh expansive but limited research is
Complicated by the fact that he ran a
very very secretive bureaucracy and so
many of those files are even today uh 51
years after his death are still redacted
are hard to access are hard to figure
out so I'd be happy to talk more about
that research project
as it evolved over the period that I
worked on it when we get to the Q a
uh but all told those variety of factors
the political puzzle that's available
Hoover as a vehicle into so many
different things over the course of the
20th century and then the wealth of a
new material that was available made me
think uh that this was a good moment to
revisit this figure that I think has
been and still is a household name but
who has been a pretty one-dimensional
figure in lots of ways and my goal in
writing a biography of him was not only
to intervene in this set of academic
conversations
um but to really sort of take him from
where he's been which is this
one-dimensional figure sort of seen as
this Rogue actor in American history and
really bring him back into a more
complicated story about the 20th century
and really bring him back into the
center of things and to the center of a
political story about this period of
time because while we tend to think of
him as someone that everyone loves to
hate there are very few people in our
own day and age who want to claim a
figure like Hoover nonetheless during
his lifetime he was enormously popular
he was enormously influential and of
course any one of those presidents all
eight of them four Democrats four
Republicans could have fired him at any
moment and did not and so the story of
his longevity his popularity the sources
of his support is also a piece of his
story that I wanted to tell in this book
and I think in many ways maybe the most
counter-intuitive piece of that story
given how widely hated and condemned he
is in our own day
so I wanted to take a few minutes now
and just put a a little more detail onto
this story of Hoover run relatively
quickly through the sections of the book
so you can get a sense of the kind of
amazing scope of his life the variety of
things that I touch upon in the book and
then as I said hopefully we can just
open this up for conversation
foreign
so this is a real you know birth to
death biography I found that in writing
a biography one of the advantages of the
biographical form uh is that it does
give you a place to start and a place to
end uh and that's what I have done I did
not try to upend the biographical form
uh and these are some of the earliest
pictures we have of Hoover I should note
this is the only actual photo of Hoover
doing what wearing a dress uh his baby
photo but Hoover is a child of
Washington DC he was born in Washington
DC in 1895 and he never left
um he's born there in 1895 he dies there
in 1972 and his biography really is a
story about Washington DC what that City
meant and how it changed over the course
of his lifetime and during his early
years I think there are two themes that
are really important important for his
future development the first is that he
was born into a world of government
service he was born on Capitol Hill just
a few blocks behind the U.S Capitol and
he was born into a family that already
in the late 19th century had Decades of
service to the federal government in the
sort of professionalized end of the
executive branch in the few places that
really were part of the federal civil
service at that point right the
government in the late 19th century
particularly the executive branch is
much much smaller and has many fewer
duties than what we are accustomed to
today but nonetheless Hoover's family
had been involved in the government and
it was the world that he was born into
his father was sort of a mid-level civil
servant and it was what Hoover saw all
around him Washington DC as the national
capital and as the federal City during
those years also meant some very
particular things the most notable of
which is that Washington D.C residents
could not vote they did not join
political parties and they could not
vote either for their own municipal
government or in federal elections so
Hoover was not only born into this
tradition of civil service but he was
born into a world that stood sort of
proudly apart from partisanship that was
a world of career service and in which
he had very little access to any sort of
democratic participation so he never saw
his parents vote he himself never joined
a political party and he never voted in
a single election
so that's one piece of the Washington
tradition that I think is really
critical for understanding
where he came from and who he became the
other piece that's really critical is
that he was born into Washington that
was essentially a conservative southern
city in the late 19th century it was a
city that was actively undergoing a
process of racial segregation have been
a pretty multi-racial city in the mid
and late 19th century but during his
childhood was actively building racial
barriers and he participated in and
witnessed and was shaped by that process
he went to segregated public schools in
Washington DC and then he went on to a
segregated private university at George
Washington University at the moment that
he joined federal employment under the
Wilson Administration was precisely the
moment that the federal government was
self-consciously and actively
segregating federal employment
throughout the executive branch so the
just two pieces this government service
tradition a tradition of racial
conservatism of active segregationist
processes go on to be really important
to Hoover as he develops over time
uh as I said he went uh to the
Washington DC public schools he does not
come from a wealthy family so he goes
through the public school system this is
him uh here as a high school Cadet uh he
was a kind of star student
um we I think tend to think of him as a
rather plotting and you know fixed old
man but he was apparently quite uh the
energetic vibrant and ambitious uh young
student in high school he was the
valedictorian of his class he was the
cadet leader of his high school class
and he was also a star debater in high
school
uh he from there went on to a really
critical period of his life which is uh
his years as a student at George
Washington University
um that matter for I would say three key
reasons uh number one uh is that in
order to earn his way through law school
at GW which was an undergraduate degree
then he had to have a day job GW at that
point was basically a night school for
future Federal civil servants and most
of them had government jobs by day and
then went to GW at night Hoover was one
of those students
he got a job at the Library of Congress
helping to sort through and establish
the Library of Congress classification
system and he learned very early on
there to build files to learn to
classify things a whole set of kind of
administrative and information
technology tools that prove important
the second is GW is his introduction to
the study of the law and then the third
is what you see up here which is that at
GW he joined a fraternity called Kappa
Alpha Kappa Alpha became not only
important to him as a young man at GW
but became the source of much of his
hiring at the FBI in the years to follow
now Kappa Alpha is a really fascinating
institution something that I didn't know
much about hadn't been written about
much before this biography but it turns
out the Kappa Alpha was a explicitly
Southern fraternity had been founded in
1865 in the wake of the Civil War
essentially to carry on the lost cause
of the white South revered Robert E Lee
had very explicit sort of racialized
Lost Cause pro-confederate politics and
by the time Hoover joined in the early
20th century was a real meeting place of
power for segregationist southern
Democrats serving in Washington D.C so
Kappa Alpha becomes a place where you
can see that Hoover's racial ideology is
a hardening really becoming much more
specific and it's also a place where he
begins to develop a political Network
that becomes incredibly important to him
a world of Southern Democrats and a
world of access to political power
these images are a couple of examples of
Kappa Alpha which he remained involved
in for all of his life um the first one
up there which is a novel called the
klansmen which became the basis for the
film Birth of a Nation written by a guy
named Thomas Dixon who is one of the
most famous Kappa Alphas of Hoover's era
he was still alive was this sort of
famous segregationist voice and of
course both the klansmen and The Birth
of a Nation are glorifications of the Ku
Klux Klan Birth of a Nation came out
while Hoover was a college student his
Kappa Alpha fraternity gets together
they screen it they're very tightly tied
into the world of the Wilson
Administration where that kind of
politics is holding Sway and this
continues for much of his life as I said
he retains a kind of lifelong allegiance
to an alliance with Kappa Alpha draws a
lot out of the first generation of FBI
officials both out of GW and Kappa Alpha
but as you can see this is an image from
the 1950s when Kappa Alpha is really
critical in popularizing uh the
Confederate flag as a symbol of
resistance to the civil rights movement
and then over there a kind of Lifetime
Achievement certificate for Hoover in
the early 60s from Kappa Alpha I should
note that they are still around this
fraternity many of these issues are
still live issues for Kappa Alpha so I
recommend Googling Kappa Alpha in our
own present day I should also say they
are not thrilled with my depiction of
them in this book I have heard from some
Kappa Alphas
um on those sorts of questions
so that is his uh really important I
think uh you know formative period in
college 1913 to 1917 and then something
happens that's really important and is
one of these uh kind of flukes of timing
uh that matters not only for Hoover but
really for for the nation for the 20th
century for the United States which is
that he happens to graduate from college
in 1917 at exactly the moment that the
United States is entering the first
world war he does not though he had been
you know a Cadet Captain does not go on
to serve in the military instead he
moves straight into the justice
department it is his first job out of
college and he never leaves so he spends
48 years as head of the FBI ultimately
he spends a total of 55 years as an
employee of the justice department
beginning in 1917. he moved into the
justice department at another really
critical period in American history a
period in which the Justice Department's
Duties are expanding very dramatically
with the war and in which they have a
deep need for sort of energetic young
lawyers to help them figure out how to
manage those new duties things like
draft enforcement as the U.S is and
engaged in large-scale Selective Service
and draft for uh the first time in many
ways they're a whole new set of speech
laws that come in during the war the
Espionage Act and the Sedition Act aimed
at War dissenters left Wingers
revolutionaries the justice department
has to figure out what to do there and
they are also given the task of figuring
out a system of internment for German
Nationals living in the United States
and that is actually Hoover's first set
of Duties at the justice department
German internment and German
registration during the war again
something that goes on to matter an
awful lot from the moment that he enters
the federal government he is charged
with these new experiments in figuring
out you know who's dangerous who's not
dangerous Who belongs who doesn't belong
whose opinion is acceptable whose
opinion is not acceptable and how are
you going to use this new legal and
administrative state that is in the
works to police those lines these are
some early archival examples of his
judgments as a young lawyer about
various
German cases
turns out that he is so good at that
that at the age of 24 as the war comes
to an end uh and these questions of what
all of this new apparatus is going to
look like and do with the war he gets
the first big promotion of his life the
thing that really brings him into the
Bureau of Investigation and that is a
promotion to the head of something
called The Radical division within the
justice department and the Bureau of
Investigation
it's really the federal government's
first peacetime experiment in how to
conduct surveillance of left-wing
radicals in the United States
particularly anarchists and communists
World War one had also of course
produced the Bolshevik Revolution had
produced a whole new set of concerns
around the globe about revolutionary
sentiment the rise of Communism and in
the United States helps to produce a
pretty dramatic Red Scare beginning in
1919 Hoover is in the thick of that he
is as a very very young man one of the
architects of the Palmer Raids which are
a series of deportation raids aimed at
anarchists and Communists that take
place in late 1919 and 1920. he spent a
lot of the rest of his career denying
that he had ever been involved in the
palm of raids because they became very
controversial and sort of notorious
symbols of civil liberties abuses but
it's clear from the archival record that
he was deeply involved that he helped to
plan those raids and that he learned
quite a lot very very quickly during
those early years one is really an
introduction to the language and set of
ideas that become the cause of his life
which is the struggle against communism
he's initiated into that very early on
as a Young Man
he writes some of the first official
briefs for the federal government about
the nature of the new communist parties
forming in the United States he really
Stakes a lot of his career and being one
of the great government experts on
communism and he's saying very similar
things in the 1940s he's saying very
similar things in the 1970s to what he
first starts to articulate in 19 and
1920 uh
during these very early years and then
the second piece is it's the moment that
he first comes into contact and then
conflict with new civil liberties
organizations that are just getting
their start and that he's going to kind
of be in it in a dance with for the rest
of his career most notably the ACLU
which has its origins in the first world
war these struggles during the Red Scare
from there despite the controversies of
uh the Palmer Raids Hoover does get
another quick promotion in 1921 as the
Democrats leave power the Republicans
come in Hoover manages uh to stay on and
gets a promotion to become assistant
director of the Bureau of Investigation
at the age of 26 and then in 1924 three
years later at the ripe old age of 29
becomes the director of the Bureau of
Investigation which is the job that he
holds for the rest of his life
so I've spent a long time on Hoover's
early years and I'm going to move a
little more quickly through the next
sections of the book so that we can get
to the Q a but I think you can see
during these early years a lot of the
themes developing that he is going to
then learn to build upon to
operationalize over the course of his
career at the head of the bureau and I
think one of the puzzles uh and uh
interesting aspects of a figure like
Hoover is that on the one hand
he has a very fixed set of ideas about
government about race about communism
about religion that are there from the
moment he begins this work to the moment
that he dies they're incredibly
consistent right his words sound
incredibly similar over the course of
that period and at the same time he is
someone who is incredibly adaptable able
to learn and in particular able to
respond to and build upon crises and in
many ways the story of the 20th century
is a story of various crises that then
produce big shifts in the government
growth of the security State as well as
the social welfare state and Hoover is
incredibly skilled at adapting to those
crises and delivering on what he thinks
the people above him particularly in the
white house as well as those below him
his popular constituency want from him
from the FBI and from the federal
government as a whole in those moments
of crisis
so the first part of the book really
focuses on his his early years from 1895
to 1924 kind of getting him to the
moment of becoming head of the bureau
part two then moves into looking at the
1920s and 1930s as the periods when he
really built the institution that we
know as the FBI it is very strange for
us to think about but when Hoover came
in in 1924 as this young new director of
The Bureau he really has brought in as a
reformer he's brought in as a kind of
energetic young reformer trained in the
law trained in Information Technology
trained in a certain kind of
professionalism and his job is to
professionalize and clean up the bureau
which has been a kind of tiny Backwater
but be a mess even at that full of
corruption uh notorious for its abuses
of civil liberties and so when Hoover
comes in the word is uh there's a new
man in town he is a young professional
steeped in uh Progressive ideas about
science about expertise about education
and really his vision when he becomes
head of the bureau is to remake it as a
kind of elite law enforcement agency
that is going to be a model of these
Progressive Era ideas about facts and
Science and expertise and education
within the world of law enforcement as
you can see here Merit often he's
contrasted with figures like Sherlock
Holmes the kind of Rogue detective right
and Hoover's men are going to be a
different kind of professional agent
he promises not to do lots of things
says they are unsuited to the work of
something like the FBI they're never
going to open people's mail they're
never going to wiretap they're never
going to coerce anyone into doing
anything
um of course this changes a little bit
over time as you will see
um and he sets about not only a kind of
uh as he would describe it cleansing the
bureaucracy but bringing in a new
generation of college-educated lawyers
and accountants who are supposed to be
these kind of shining white-collar
professional law enforcement symbols
many of them come straight out of his
beloved institutions both George
Washington University and Kappa Alpha
this is a newspaper feature on the many
young GW men who are remaking the bureau
in the 20s and 30s the most important of
those men is this fellow here named
Clyde Tolson Clyde Tolson was a graduate
of GW he graduated a few years after
Hoover entered the bureau in 1928
and went on very quickly to rise to the
number two position at the bureau and to
occupy that position at Hoover's right
hand for the rest of his life as well
now Clyde Tolson of course if you know
anything about J Edgar Hoover is not
just the associate director of the FBI
but is it also in many ways Hoover's
life partner his social partner and the
closest thing that Hoover ever had to
espouse there are lots of I think
interesting things to say about Hoover's
sexuality and I'm happy to talk more
about that I do write quite a lot about
it in the book but I'll just say a few
things right now
one is that Tolson is by far the most
important relationship in his life
Hoover does not get married he does not
have children but he and Tolson really
relate to each other as a social couple
in the way that you might expect that
spouses would they not only work
together they have all of their meals
together they vacation together they
socialize together and they're pretty
widely accepted in wash Washington New
York Florida California the places that
they spend their time together as a
social couple so there are lots of nice
scenes in the book of you know Hoover
and and Clyde double dating with say
dick and Pat Nixon
um and so Hoover's life his private life
his social life his intimate life is I
would say a funny combination of on the
one hand being very very public and open
um and then of course having lots of
Secrets as well
um I'll show you a little bit about
Hoover and Tolson so this is one of my
favorite pictures of them together this
is a celebration of tolson's 20 years at
the FBI I think it was his 20th it might
have been his 15th but uh one of
tolson's anniversaries at the FBI and
what I like about this is not only that
they're wearing matching suits and
standing in a sea of flowers but it
looks kind of like a wedding photo right
but that's the closest we have uh to
that I think the more interesting photos
and one of the places that I really
tried to access not only their public
life together which as I said is very
open right I mean their Broadway shows
and nightclubs and vacations and all
over the place together the horse track
the baseball game
but a little bit more of their
interiority what did any of this mean to
them one of the best sources for that
was Hoover's private photo album I've
reproduced some of those photos there
but that photo album is really filled
with fairly intimate portraits
particularly in the 30s and 40s of their
vacations together in places like Miami
and California so here's a shot
presumably taken by Tolson of of Hoover
at the beach
getting getting dressed this is Tolson
on a fishing boat a photo taken by
Hoover and there are dozens and dozens
of these photos uh you know really quite
intimate photos of the two of them
together and there are other ways to I
think begin to get at what they what
they meant to each other but these are
some of my favorite sources of course
then in thinking about Hoover and Tolson
as a couple there are a couple of
complications of one we don't know of
course whether this was in fact a sexual
relationship or not two is that they
came of age and were deeply interested
in and involved in policing the sex
lives of other gay people particularly
in the 40s 50s and 60s when it was
federal policy that you could not be gay
and be employed in the federal
government so Hoover is on the one hand
involved in this very public open
intimate social partnership with his
number two at the FBI and then on the
other hand is actively policing the
sexual and private lives of thousands of
federal civil servants and to complicate
matters further of course when anyone
suggested as many many people did over
the course of Hoover's life that perhaps
Hoover himself was gay or queer or
homosexual right in the language of the
time they might actually get an FBI
agent showing up to their door knocking
on it and saying you know we've heard
you've been spreading these rumors about
the director of the FBI you know we're
sure you don't want to say such girlist
things about the most wonderful
important Federal servant we've ever
seen and of course people
um were a little frightened in those
situations but he really used the power
of the bureau that he created to police
his own reputation and to police the
boundaries
of what was known about his own intimate
life
so I'm happy to talk more about that in
the Q a uh that relationship plays a big
role in the book but I want to say a few
other things about what happens in the
30s and 40s um as Hoover is the head of
the FBI and probably the most surprising
thing is that uh it is really during the
New Deal that he ends up acquiring most
of his power and influence uh he spends
a lot of the 20s and 30s kind of engaged
in building up the scientific end of the
bureau the fingerprint division uh get
in control of crime statistics right
when you hear crime statistics today
that's because J Edgar Hoover in the 30s
demanded that the FBI be in control of
crime statistics so if you hear the FBI
uniform crime reports today that comes
from Hoover's years setting up the FBI
lab setting up its Academy setting up
these new training facilities to
professionalize the bureau yeah during
the 1920s these are the Glamor Shots of
the FBI that Hoover likes to promote
there are sort of endless numbers of
shots of just filing cabinets right guys
standing at filing cabinets uh showing
off how much they know that they are you
know white collar paper pushers Etc but
this is this is the the Hoover's
favorite image of the bureau in the
1920s and then suddenly in the mid 1930s
that all begins to change uh by 1935 and
1936 you're not seeing filing cabinets
but you're seeing uh the famous images
of FBI agents with Tommy Guns as great
crime Fighters
the main thing that happens in the 1930s
to produce the FBI that we know today is
that Franklin Roosevelt and the state
Builders of the New Deal look to the FBI
to become the sort of federal standard
bearers for what they describe as a war
on crime in the 1930s so suddenly
Hoover's nice white collar lawyers and
accountants are told beginning in 1934
and 35 that they are actually going to
be gun wielding policemen some of them
have no idea how to shoot a gun they had
no expectation that this was going to be
their job but in the midst of a new deal
push to go after a wave of kind of
high-profile kidnappers bank robbers
figures like John Dillinger you see a
radical change at the FBI and that's
where we begin to get this very
different image and Hoover responds to
that crisis quickly that happens through
crime LED legislation and as you can see
through some of these images the FBI
becomes essentially a new deal alphabet
agency right they become symbols of
these new forms of federal power that
are going to intervene not only in
solving the economic pressions and
problems of the new deal but are going
to be much more involved in law
enforcement as well so here they are
fighting kidnapping
along the way Hoover begins to develop
what become becomes one of his signature
features as a bureaucrat which is his
Public Relations Division encouraged by
Franklin Roosevelt who says you know you
can't just accept that people understand
the work of government you've got to
sell it to them you've got to explain to
them what the federal government is
doing Hoover becomes really a master of
publicity Hollywood movies
newspaper reports Etc begin to glorify
him and really turn him into a celebrity
in the 1930s and then the last thing
that happens in the 1930s and into the
40s is that the FBI moves much more
aggressively into the world of domestic
intelligence Espionage in ways that are
fundamentally new and it's under
Franklin Roosevelt that the FBI really
begins to do the work that we associate
with it today on the one hand to be a
Federal criminal law enforcement agency
and on the other hand to be our domestic
intelligence agency dealing with things
like like Espionage and in particular
with political intelligence surveillance
and kind of mass political surveillance
the other thing that happens by the end
of the war is that the FBI has
quadrupled in size so Hoover started out
in the 1920s with this tiny little group
of a few hundred agents a few hundred
people in the fingerprint division this
is his filing cabinets by the end of the
war this is the Washington Armory the
FBI Moves In And as you can see he now
by the end of the war really has an army
of his own
so that is part two of the book uh this
period of institution building that
moves from the 20s through the 40s I'll
just say a few words about the last two
sections of the book which I think in
many ways are the periods that most
people today know best when they think
about Hoover when they think about the
FBI and its history
the first of those is the period in the
late 40s and into the 1950s uh when I
would say Hoover has finished a lot of
building the FBI and then puts it to
work for the causes that he cares about
most and above all puts them to work in
the cause of fighting communism they've
been doing some of that work in the 40s
during the war but as the war comes to
an end the Cold War begins to emerge
Hoover very quickly becomes one of the
most prominent voices of anti-communism
in the United States this is the cover
of Newsweek by 1947 already looking to
Hoover as a national spokesman for the
anti-communist cause and really for
trying to raise the level of alarm in
the United States around the question of
communism
I think there are a couple of things
that are worth noting about
the way that Hoover relates to this
question and why he's really important
as I said in the 20s 30s through the war
he's really building the bureau he is
not doing uh I think as much
following of his own agenda as we begin
to see during this period when he's
really secured the institutional heft of
the FBI has secured his own public
profile and then can really begin to
shape public opinion and to shape
Washington politics in much more
autonomous ways
it is possible to imagine an FBI
director in the 1940s faced with the
emerging Cold War who takes a pretty
narrow view of National Security right
says that I am you know a federal law
enforcement agent and the head of our
domestic political police but in that
role my job is to look into questions of
Espionage perhaps to keep an eye on the
Communist party which is in fact you
know cooperating with Soviet agents
during these years both around Espionage
and is taking money from the Soviet
Union and that's where my job ends right
that's what a national security and law
enforcement profile looks like
Hoover sort of does the opposite he does
that kind of work and there's lots of
interesting stuff to say about the big
Espionage cases of those years but he
makes himself a kind of cultural icon a
political force in defining the struggle
against communism in the broadest ways
possible so to Hoover you know it is not
only a matter of Espionage or of
containing the role of the Communist
party but he really frames
anti-communism as an existential
struggle that involves every person in
the United States and that is constantly
being fought out in every institution in
the United States from universities to
public schools to churches to the
government itself and that involves
every aspect of people's lives from race
relations to religion
to family structure and on and on and so
he's engaged in a lot of very kind of
technical investigations on the one hand
and then on the other hand he is pouring
out a whole series of books articles
films framing the Communist question in
very
um dramatic and as I said sort of
existential ways
couple of other things to note about
this period one is that it's a period
when he begins to work very closely with
congressional committees especially
committees like the house committee uh
on American activities the Senate
internal security subcommittee uh uh
congressional committees that are
involved in the kind of work that he
cares about one of my favorite chapters
in the book is about his starting in the
1940s as a variety of these committees
need professional staff to agree to
start Staffing them with FBI agents and
so he gets this very dramatic inroad
into Congress the Appropriations
Committee hughac a whole series of
committees end up staffed by FBI agents
which means he has access to lots of
information lots of influence and and
lots of important ties to Congress just
one symbol of his bureaucratic skill
this is Hoover testifying in front of
Congress in 1953 in the Harry Dexter
white spy case
the other is his relationship to Joseph
McCarthy so this is a photo of a
vacation photo with Hoover and Tolson
let's see Hoover's over here on my left
Tolson is the second one from the right
there and that's Joe McCarthy on the end
so they're all vacationing together out
in California in some ways they are
social friends they obviously share a
set of anti-communist commitments but
what was more interesting to me were the
ways in which Hoover and McCarthy
ultimately diverge Hoover becomes seen
popularly in the white house as well as
among liberals as the more responsible
alternative to Joe McCarthy who ends up
depicted as uh the kind of demagogue the
Loose Canon the liar so in our minds I
think these two are often kind of
conflated together but in the politics
of their moment they were seen as very
different sorts of figures and in fact
it's Hoover that many liberals end up
rallying behind as sort of an
alternative to Joe McCarthy
I'll just show a few examples as well of
Hoover's broader cultural impact so this
is uh you know a a bus bench I think
it's in Houston is that what it says up
there at any rate um I said that Hoover
was not only this kind of technocrat but
this uh significant popular and cultural
figure this is him fighting uh communism
he wrote a bestseller called masters of
Deceit that many people were forced to
read as young children telling you how
you could participate in the fight
against communism this is Hoover
lecturing American families about how to
raise their children which you know
people would occasionally point out
they're not sure where he gets his
expertise on that question and then
finally in the 50s as I said Hoover's
this important cultural figure on uh
anti-communism but it also becomes a
very sort of outspoken religious voice
and plays a big role in the kind of
surge of religiosity that's so important
to the conservative politics of of the
1950s
all right I will finish up very quickly
uh just with the period of the 60s and
70s which as I said I think are the most
familiar to many people today and really
are the period when uh Hoover becomes uh
if not a less influential figure a less
universally popular figure by the late
1950s his popularity ratings are in the
70s 80s 90 percentiles that begins to
fall off a little bit in the 1960s as
the country's politics change and as he
ages
so the last part of the book is this
period from 1960 up to his death in 1972
that covers what I think are three of
the most interesting presidential
relationships in the book uh the first
is his relationship with the Kennedy
administration and uh what I love about
this picture is that I think it sort of
captures that relationship which it was
not a happy one um they really didn't
like each other uh and John Kennedy is
one of those figures who might have uh
fired Hoover he certainly thought about
it he considered it and thought that it
was not a good idea for a variety of
reasons Hoover was particularly hostile
to Bobby Kennedy who of course was made
attorney general under his brother's
presidency at a at a fairly young age I
found myself actually surprisingly
sympathetic to Hoover who is in his
early 60s that is saying why is there
this 35 year old attorney general he
doesn't seem very qualified and I don't
really like him
um but at any rate
theirs is an interesting relationship as
well it then goes on to Hoover's
relationship with Lyndon Johnson uh and
I think we would tend to think of Hoover
and Johnson as being on opposite sides
of things like
um civil rights other major political
trends of the 1960s Johnson as a great
liberal icon Hoover increasingly can
seen as a far-right conservative but
actually they got along really well and
they cooperated in pretty dramatic and
often quite outrageous ways in the 1960s
they had been Neighbors on the same
Block in Washington so they knew each
other from the 1940s onward and it's
really Lyndon Johnson that we can thank
or blame for making J Edgar Hoover
essentially FBI director for Life had
things gone their normal course Hoover
would have been forced to retire at at
the age of 70 that would have been
January 1st
1965 but Lyndon Johnson decided to
exempt him from the mandatory Federal
retirement age and this is the ceremony
in 1964 where Johnson says that he wants
Hoover to stay on now why did Johnson
want Hoover to stay on
um
it's an interesting question but as I
said they had this long-standing
relationship and also Johnson went on to
use Hoover and the FBI more aggressively
than almost any other president
sometimes that was in the service of
civil rights enforcement Johnson really
pushed the FBI to be more aggressive
about civil rights enforcement
particularly after the civil rights
legislation of that era
but he also used the FBI pretty
aggressively to police the Civil Rights
Movement to police the left one of the
more outrageous moments is when Johnson
asks the FBI to conduct surveillance
wiretapping infiltration of civil rights
demonstrators at the 1964 Democratic
National Convention on his behalf and to
and to report back to him what was going
on there with the Mississippi Freedom
Democratic Party
at any rate there's a lot about Hoover
and Johnson it's a really interesting
complicated and I think
counter-intuitive relationship in many
ways and there's a lot about Richard
Nixon as well um which is probably the
most long-standing and closest
presidential relationship of Hoover's
life They too had been very close since
the 1940s this is them vacationing
together as well in the 1950s but they
run into some conflicts when Nixon
becomes president and theirs is a it is
an interesting and complicated
relationship as well
that section of the book also goes into
a lot of the big investigations of the
era most notably uh the Kennedy
assassination and the King assassination
I should say in writing the book there
were a few sections that I really
dreaded having to get into those were
among them because the volume of
material related to those cases is so
vast the little literature related to
those cases is so vast that so much of
it is so bizarre and terrible and I had
to wade into that but the real thrust of
this final section is about Hoover's
political policing in the 1960s uh
particularly the FBI's campaigns against
the civil rights movement against the
new left and against figures like Martin
Luther King
in which the FBI conducted not only a
pretty aggressive public campaign to
discredit King and destabilize the
movement but also a whole series of
pretty outrageous secret activities
including wiretapping King's Home and
Office phones planting bugs in his hotel
rooms to record his sex life sending
those recordings to King along with
Anonymous threatening notes and
deploying those sorts of tactics not
only against King but against a wide
variety of figures on the left as well
as to some degree on the right as well
probably the most famous of those
programs in the 1960s is a program known
as cointelpro
which was started in the late 50s as a
program aimed at the Communist Party
expanded over the course of the 1960s to
become a program of surveillance and
disruption aimed at nearly every
organization on the left from the Civil
Rights Movement to the Black Panthers to
student activists it was a program that
involved not only surveillance
wiretapping Etc but active disruptive
techniques sending in informants to
disrupt meetings planting false
newspaper allegations working with local
police to set up activists
for arrest
Etc it's worth noting here that most of
this was aimed at the politics of the
left but the FBI did employ some of
those techniques against the Ku Klux
Klan against Neo-Nazi organizations
white supremacist organizations in the
1960s so I think even even in this
period you know Hoover has a more
complicated story than is often
portrayed in the public discourse
although you know the basic thrust of
cointelpro as a pretty destructive
outrageous and illegal program that had
a dramatic effect on the civil rights
movement in particular but the new Left
more broadly I think is basically
correct
and then we end up back
uh here in 1972 with with Hoover's
funeral as I said he sort of died uh
with his boots on uh as FBI director in
May of 1972 and at the moment that he
died there was a lot of uh celebration
among those who hated him but I would
say more broadly you know reflection on
the fact that whatever you thought of
what he had accomplished he had been
really a central figure in the politics
of the 20th century a central figure in
the politics of Washington over that
time period And as Richard Nixon said in
his eulogy for Hoover one of the Giants
of American history and so my goal in
writing this book was to sort of take
him from what I think he had become in
the 21st century which is sort of a
one-dimensional caricature and bring him
back into the center of of this politics
where he had his hands in so much but
where he wasn't just acting on his own
he was acting in concert with many
figures in the white house with many
figures and Congress
um and was an enormously kind of popular
uh and influential public servant For
Better or For Worse
so I will leave my remarks there I'm
happy to uh you know take questions in
whatever form you think makes sense Ty
yeah
well first of all
[Applause]
uh wonderful talk on a great subject
um
finished re-reading 1984. cointelpro by
the way is a great new speak word first
to me right maybe that wasn't lost on
Hoover
um and of course Orwell is
the idea that technological and
advancements would be developed and
employed in the surveillance and the
advancement surveillance individual
citizens
and uh like the telescreens in that
novel so you talked a bit about about
Hoover's
science which you described as
and how did they uh figure into what
became
and uh his work at the FBI yeah great
that's a it's a really important
question and it's a big theme of his
career so when he uh became director in
the 1920s he advertised himself as kind
of one of the great expositors of
something called scientific policing and
scientific policing was supposed to make
police uh more effective and as Hoover
would have described it less brutal at
the same time so what scientific
policing really meant was a couple of
things one was harnessing a new set of
social science tools that could be put
to the work of law enforcement so that
was everything from new classification
and filing systems
to things like fingerprints which are
just coming in as a form of of
identification to crime statistics right
there was no I mean in the 1920s early
30s there's a lot of talk about this as
a crisis in the United States but there
were no National crime statistics being
gathered in any effective way so you had
perceptions of uh growing forms of crime
you have new things like the automobile
and the Machine Gun coming in as tools
that are allowing first greater degrees
of violence in some ways but are
allowing criminals to Cross Federal
lines across state lines
and so there are all sorts of
technological changes that are then
driving this push for crime statistics
so Hoover is very serious about wanting
to get control of crime statistics
because he saw it one of these place
cases where the FBI could be effective
as a rather small organization it could
be in touch with every Police Department
in the country in order to collect these
statistics and so that that was going to
be important for his kind of
institutional influence and then it was
going to allow him to influence and
Define what crime was how it was counted
as well as what public perceptions would
be so scientific policing is on the one
hand this set of kind of
professionalizing and social science
tools that includes the FBI Academy and
then on the other hand there's this
whole world of forensic science that is
just starting to open up so fingerprints
fit over there as well a little bit but
one of his signature developments in the
early 30s is the FBI crime lab which is
still the FBI crime lab that we know
today which has had its own uh sort of
failures and Scandals over the last 20
years but his vision was that he was
going to employ a bunch of chemists and
scientists who would be able to be the
nation's top forensic experts so that
when local police ran into problems they
could send their evidence into the FBI
the FBI could help them to figure out
what was going on and they would get
that information back down to the local
police level because of course in our
country almost all to this day almost
just all law enforcement is done at the
local level and so to be a federal law
enforcement agency or even a federal
intelligence agency but in law
enforcement in particular Hoover always
had this problem which is that relative
to the scope of the country the FBI was
Tiny and that it didn't have actually a
lot of jurisdiction or it had very weird
areas of jurisdiction and that is still
true today
and so he saw these not only as places
of kind of scientific progress but he
also saw them as sort of strategic
points of intervention a role that the
that the bureau could play and I think
it's still a really important part of
the of the FBI's image this kind of you
know I mean how many television shows do
we still have that are about you know
kind of elite forensics Labs that are
often at the federal level that are
doing the work that Hoover envisioned
did Hoover seem to run off the rails in
the 60s
and do you think that the student
protests had anything to do with that
yeah the 60s were definitely the period
in which I think what what he had built
up in the 50s which was very bipartisan
support and very widespread public
support really begins to fracture and a
lot of it has to do with you know his
attitudes toward and public campaigns
against student activists the Civil
Rights Movement right I think he took
a lot of what he had done both in terms
of formal techniques and in terms of
publicity with the Communist Party in
the 50s and kind of transferred that
over to the new left into the social
movements of the 60s but of course the
Communist Party wasn't very popular in
the 1950s whereas those movements
actually had a real popular
constituencies a lot of uh you know a
lot of people who uh who supported them
and so it didn't his formula suddenly
didn't work uh in the 1960s so some of
that I think was generational right he
was getting much older he seemed much
more uh sort of out of touch with the
new generations of students some of it
was that he sort of couldn't get out of
a a sort of Cold War mentality so he's
constantly accusing Martin Luther King
of being a communist accusing student
activists of being tools of the
Communists right the anti-war movement
and it didn't work as well in the 60s
and then I think there was also just a
sort of changing civil liberties
Consciousness in that decade where
techniques that were once deemed you
know tolerable or acceptable you know
you were really seeing a different set
of Assessments about individual rights
about civil liberties and so a lot of
Hoover's techniques as well also came
under a lot more a lot more scrutiny
um I was gonna ask what
sources give you like it sounds like
he's a very political person and I'm
wondering where you felt like you got
the most Frankin honest access to his
voice and his thinking and his mind in
correspondence or anything else
well I think there are a couple of
different things that come to mind so
one is are the FBI Files themselves
which as I said have all sorts of
problems right they're police files
um and so they have certain you know
obvious biases Etc they also are often
redacted so you can't find out
everything that's in them my personal
favorite file on that front is the FBI's
file on the CIA
which you know has page after page where
they say you know dear director the most
interesting thing happened today and
then it's all just black right so you
can't actually have access to any other
page after page of of redaction
um but the advantage of those FBI Files
is that during Hoover's lifetime he
believed that no one else would ever
have Act
there was no Freedom of Information Act
there were no Congressional intelligence
committees and in fact there was no
mechanism aside from the courts which
occasionally cost you know forced the
FBI to cough something up uh Hoover
believed he had total control over those
files and therefore they're pretty
candid in these files both about you
know when you read their files on Martin
Luther King and what they're plotting
against him and they just write it all
down and that's true in many many
instances and then Hoover himself had a
habit of writing things in the margins
so he had a blue pen he could write
things in the margins and so he's just
scrawling all of these um
often you know kind of epithets and his
true opinions of many people
um so those I actually think are are
pretty direct access and then
the most direct and literal access to
his voice are the Johnson and Nixon
tapes which are really interesting
because he had very close relationships
with both of them lots of their phone
conversations are recorded and you
listen to them and they are talking
about a vast array of things and
um
yeah and and they're often pretty Frank
with each other in those
I'm not sure if you're familiar with
with the organization that's called the
family that there's been a lot written
about it over the years and and you know
it claim that Supreme Court Justices and
senators and and your research did you
find any connection between Hoover and
the family
find Direct connections and I'm
generally familiar with the with the
family without knowing
um all of the specifics
um but Hoover's relationship with the
right with right-wing organizations and
with you know a certain kind of nascent
religious right that's beginning to
emerge during his lifetime was really
interesting to me
though a lot of the kind of conservative
movement that starts in the 50s and into
the 60s
kind of takes aim at Federal bureaucrats
right as the as the worst people in the
world is anti-statist in lots of ways
right a kind of buckley-ite critique of
the of the federal government Hoover was
always the one Federal servant lifetime
career bureaucrat that they loved
um and one of the places that this
emerges pretty dramatically is with the
John Birch Society right which in many
ways is kind of a forerunner of the of
the sorts of organizations that you're
talking about John Birch Society far
right kind of Grassroots
anti-communist organization in the late
50s and early 60s and the John Birch
Society loves Hoover right they are
constantly assigning his books they're
sort of saying you know the great
Authority J Edgar Hoover says you know
the Communist Menace is here and it will
never go away and we all have to
participate in this but Hoover himself
was actually pretty skeptical of groups
like the John Birch Society because he
thought they were extremists they were a
little out of control and so there's a
real ambivalence there so you know I
think that that would be sort of his his
relationship with an organization like
the family
the only other thing that I would say is
that Hoover was himself
you know I think he he considered
himself a kind of deeply religious
Christian
he didn't go to church all that often
from what I can tell but he spoke often
particularly in the 1950s about the need
for religiosity he had uh you know send
all your children to Sunday school he
had been a Sunday school teacher and I
think institutionally he then begins to
bring a lot of that into the FBI so he
begins to hire Mormons in much greater
numbers and Catholics in much greater
numbers in the 50s and 60s and he begins
to bring a set of kind of religious
rituals communion breakfasts prayer
breakfasts into the FBI itself so there
are ways in which he's doing some of
that uh similar kind of work within uh
within the bureau itself
so it sounds like with with the
religious uh
part of his life
lukewarm as maybe it was uh
there's that dichotomy again between
what he is portraying or what he's
advocating for right and what he's
really living same thing with if I had a
son was that the book
looking at at his his photo album and
his writings the marginalia
uh that you surely poured over for years
what is your sense of where he was
mentally with that dichotomy is it this
is self-aggrandizement for career
advancement or he could he was
skillfully enough to occupy both fears
and do it you know to his bureaucratic
success where I mean how did he square
that
that's a great question and I'm not sure
I found the final answer to that
question
um
right right there there's one of my
favorite discoveries that helped me get
a little sense of that maybe is that um
in 1950 he was on vacation with Clyde
Tolson in Los Angeles and a reporter
started following them around they
didn't see the reporter but you know
they went to the farmers market together
they went and got ice cream cones
together uh and then they went to a
bookstore and this reporter was
following them and the reporter looked
at the books that they were buying and
Tolson was buying a couple of westerns
you know Beach reading but Hoover was
buying two books by a psychoanalyst
named Karen hornet
um who was a famous psychoanalyst of
that period wrote popular books her
papers are actually here at Yale
and one was called our inner conflict
and the other was called self-analysis
and so I was like I'm gonna read these
books and you know the Yale libraries
being what they are there were Karen
Hornet's books and so uh in particular
our inner conflicts was about precisely
what you're saying what it does when
your Public Image is so radically
different from the self that you know
and what that does to someone to have
that kind of radical difference you're
one thing in public you're another thing
in private and you have to you have to
live with that and the premise of that
book was that it produced a certain kind
of grandiosity a certain sort of
rigidity and a kind of hyper policing of
your Public Image and of those around
you right a heightened need for control
Etc and it was kind of remarkable so I
don't know if we can take this and
therefore apply it directly to Hoover
although there were a lot of features of
that that did resonate with who he was
but what was interesting to me is that
it seemed that he himself was actually
trying to sort out that question right
in ways that he couldn't speak about
publicly maybe he spoke about with
friends maybe it had to do with his
sexuality I mean some of it must have
had to do with his sexuality
um but but there were other aspects of
his life where that applied as well so
all I can say is that you know there are
glimmers that he was asking those
questions even if
I think it's fascinating um that the
the the concept of the deep state is
living with us to become new and it
seems like uh that his his role in
creating what now people think of as the
Deep safe so or what do you think about
his his sort of ongoing Legacy or both
with the nation and with the right yeah
so one of the things that's been really
fascinating to me over the last five
years really during the Trump era
is to see a kind of dramatic reversal in
uh what we got really from the end of
Hoover's life up until fairly recently
which is uh politics in which you know
in the wake of Hoover's death and then
the church committee investigations of
the 1970s which were investigations into
the FBI the CIA that really produced
some of the knowledge we have about all
of their abuses
um over the course of the 20th century
in that moment coming out of the 1960s
you had a pretty consistent
set of political sentiments in which
Democrats liberals and leftists were
much more critical of the FBI in
particular than Republicans
conservatives right Republicans and
conservatives tended to love the FBI
Democrats liberals progressives be very
suspicious of it and today that has
flipped very dramatically and some of
that simply has to do with you know the
Trump era investigations themselves I
think has to do with uh you know a
broader sense that the the part of the
FBI that is in fact about you know
fact-finding and expertise and law
enforcement is is itself worth
protecting in a period when you know
facts seem to be up for debate
um but so now we have as you're saying a
situation in which you know a lot of the
most uh vocal deep State critiques are
coming from the right and I think you
can see a little bit of that during
Hoover's years I mean particularly among
white supremacist groups in the white
South there's always a lot of resistance
to Federal Authority
um to the FBI and so I think you can see
some of those strains coming out now and
of course there's always been a sort of
libertarian critique of the security
state of federal surveillance the Deep
State
um but uh but yeah it seems very
consistent now there's no question
Hoover is an architect of that and some
of that politics come out of his era you
know James Comey blurbed the book read
the book and is someone that I I've had
a few conversations with over the years
about Hoover and you know both looking
at him from the outside and then just
speaking with him a little bit about the
these issues I do think that the FBI has
also often been in a very difficult
position where it's situated in the
executive branch it is supposed to be
non-partisan fact-finding right outside
of politics and yet again and again in
its history it gets dragged into these
incredibly politicized investigations
incredibly partisan situations where
it's legitimately quite difficult to
figure out what to do right Hoover had
that experience quite often especially
in the 60s around the major
assassinations later on for the FBI
around Watergate
and I think you can see exactly that
structural tension at play right now and
it so happens that you know it's playing
out in a very particular partisan way
at the moment but yes defund the FBI is
not coming from from the left in this
moment right it is it is it is a
right-wing slogan
um he was in Prior you said for 48 years
how do you think he maintained that
power
um so consistently and number two is you
mentioned President Kennedy wanting to
maybe fire him why do you think he did
not
well I think those questions are are
related to each other
um and I think the easy answer are
probably the most popular answer to how
Hoover stayed in power for so much that
he had the goods right that he had files
on lots of important people and the
media in politics in the White House and
Congress I mean there is actually there
is some truth to that and it's certainly
the case with uh John Kennedy that the
FBI knew an awful lot
um about uh Kennedy's sex life they knew
an awful lot about you know kind of
overt action decisions that the Kennedys
had made they knew for instance that
John Kennedy shared a girlfriend with
the head of the Chicago mob right so
pretty pretty compromising stuff and
Kennedy knew that the FBI knew that and
um so you know I think that's at least
part of the story particularly in
Hoover's later years when he has such a
concentration of power but
you know one of the things that I wanted
to really bring out in the book is that
I don't think you can understand his
power simply as this form of coercion
because he had lots of support as well
over the course of his career and he was
incredibly skilled at building that
support so the main reason that many
presidents didn't fire him is that he
was really really useful to them right
he would do their bidding he would keep
their secrets he was occasionally you
know resistant in ways that they didn't
appreciate but often was incredibly
accommodating to
the White House wanted done so he had
control over his bureaucracy he did what
presidents wanted and they saw a value
in him but he was also really good at uh
you know creating a popular constituency
the FBI built up relationships with
organizations like the American Legion
Daughters of the American Revolution
and they sort of anytime anyone
critiqued the FBI you know every
American Legion Post would sort of rise
up in protest about our great heroic FBI
director so he was very good at that he
had a huge amount of energy devoted to
public relations and to press relations
in particular so had lots of columnists
in his pocket who would also rise to his
defense and as I suggested in talking
about congressional committees he was
really smart about building a series of
kind of mutually beneficial
relationships with congressmen and
senators in particular a lot a lot of
whom really liked him and really really
supported him so to go back to Kennedy
but I think this is indicative of his
power more broadly
Kennedy did not like him personally they
didn't get along that well but Kennedy
knew that Hoover had a lot of
information the ability to get that
information out and Kennedy also says
that he actually thinks that Jay Hoover
is a more popular and B has a more loyal
political constituency than Kennedy
himself does and so you know they they
thought Hoover was more powerful more
popular and not a place to uh
waste a lot of political capital
[Applause]
[Music]